ER my talk is on a logical and causal
inference um truth counterfactual scope
and
invariance so where is
the okay um in his web page ER Zena
Tavarez whose web page I looked at
before this conference says I want to
understand how humans reason how they
come to derive Knowledge from observing
and interacting with the
world and uh this is also what I want to
understand and in this talk I will
pursue this interest by examining two
types of inference that are often
thought to be very different from each
other logical inference and causal
inference logical inference allegedly
has nothing to do with the world causal
inference has everything to do with the
world I will examine the nature of these
inferences by using three
parameters one truth in the strong sense
of factual truth or truth in the world H
not linguistic truth or coherentist
truth or pragmatist truth and
counterfactual scope and
invariance my result will be one
contrary to expectations logical and
causal inferences are similar with
respect to truth in the world two they
are different with respect to
counterfactual scope and invariance but
only in
degree
truth logic is usually thought to have
nothing to do with the world hence with
truth in the world logic is said to be
analytic I.E based on language or
meaning regardless of how the world
happens to be or necessarily is The
Logical inference and here I use same
kind of inference as Alex um one p pa or
PB not PA therefore p B is of the same
kind as the linguistic
inference a is a bachelor therefore a is
unmarried and different in kind from
hume's relevant example of a causal
inference a hit B therefore B moved
where A and B are say bilard b a
BS now inference three a hit B therefore
be
moved H depends on the way the world is
and a certain regularity in the world as
hum said a connection in the world
between two
events but the common view is one and
two don't depend on the way the world is
they don't depend on any regularity in
the world they depend on the way our
language is and the meaning of words and
a conventional connection between words
in our
language carab or an The Language game
we happen to be playing wienstein
now all three
inferences The Logical the linguistic
and the
causal guarantee the transmission of
truth from the premises to conclusion
that's why there are
inferences indeed they guarantee the
transmission of Truth in the world from
premises to conclusion assuming the
premises are true in the world the
conclusion is guaranteed to be true in
the world but while the transmission of
Truth in the causal influence is due to
a connection between things or event in
the world the transmission of Truth in
the linguistic inference is is due to a
connection between words in our language
Bachelor and unmar and the view is the
transmission of Truth in The Logical
inference is also a do is also thought
to be true due to a connection between
words on this view the correctness the
correctness of a is a bachelor therefore
a is unmarried is due to a connection
between its non-logical words Bachelor
and unmarried and the correctness of The
Logical inference p a o PB not PA
therefore PB is due to a connection
between its logical words or and
not but does this mean that one is
grounded only or mainly in
language the sentences in the inference
in The Logical inference say something
about the world the first premise says
that in the world at least one of the
two individuals A and B is in P or has
the property P the second premise says
that in the world a is in the complement
of p and the conclusion says that in the
world B is in
P Now The Logical words or symbols in
this inference could have meant
something different from what they mean
if negation meant
affirmation the inference would not have
been valid but that would not change the
fact that in the world there is a
connection between at least one X and Y
is in p and X is in the complement of p
and Y is in P this is a connection in
the world and it is this connection in
the world rather than our linguistic
conventions or the language game we
happen to play that is responsible for
the logical validity of
one in this way The Logical validity of
PA or PB not PA therefore PB is similar
in kind to the causal validity of a hit
B therefore B moved they are due to
certain regularities that hold in the
world a causal regularity in the case of
three a formal regularity in the case of
one it is for this reason the truth in
the world is transmitted from premises
to conclusions both in one one and in
two so not only are the sentences of one
and three true or false in the strong
sense of being true or false in the
world their inferential power is due to
relevant regularities or Connections in
the
world this is further seen by the fact
that no relevant regularities or
connections exist in that when no
relevant regularities or connections
exist in the world the correspondence
corresponding inferences are
invalid for example since in the world
there is no regular connection between
bilard ball a being stationary and
billyard ball be
moving the inference a stationary for a
is moving is in invalid a causal
inference similarly since in the world
there is no connection between one at
least one of X and Y being in p and X
being in p as you can see in the a
picture the N to Y being in the
complement of B of P the inference PA a
or PB this is a different from the
original PA therefore not PB is not
logically valid it is a game it could be
an influential game but it's not valid
there's nothing in the world that
connects the two
parts let us see a case in which
accepting an inference like one prime
that's PA a or PB PA therefore not PB an
influence that fails in the world and
acting upon it can bring about death in
the world and not just losing a game
suppose A and B are mushrooms p is means
poisonous and in the world mushroom B is
poisonous this is compatiable with the
premises of both the valid logical
argument one and the invalid a game
argument One Prime p a o PB at Le at
least one is poisonous and a is not
poisonous we didn't say anything about a
or a is poisonous being true but while
the game inference One Prime gives us
license to eat mushroom B it says it's
not poisonous that will kill us the
worldly difference
one does not there is a life and death
difference between one between one which
is grounded in the world and one prime
which is grounded in a convention or a
game and the same holds in other cases
just as using an incorrect aerodynamical
laws in building an airplane can cause
the airplane to crash so using incorrect
logical laws in designing an airplane
can cause it to crash H once I played
the game of creating a logic in which uh
when you give instruction lift you get
drag when you give drag you get lift
because the logic tells you to do
so conclusion logical inferences like
causal inferences are based on
regularities in the world physical
regularities in the case of causal
inferences formal regularities in the
case of logical
inferences two counterfactual or modal
scope we have seen that logical and
causal inferences are similar with
respect to truth in the world next let
us turn to their counterfactual scope or
modal
Force inferences are divided into we
weak material and stronger
non-material weak H here we have a we go
from premises to conclusion and there's
only very weak requirement it cannot be
the case that all the premises are true
and the conclusion is false where truth
means true actually true in the actual
world no
more no requirement of irregularity in
the world that connects the premises to
the
conclusion for example here is an
example of a material inference San
Diego is in California therefore New
Haven is in Conneticut this is
materially correct because the
consequence the conclusion is correct is
true and there's no regularity in the
world that's material
inference causal and logical inference
say are stronger they require regularity
indeed a strong regularity one that
includes counterfactual cases hence
inferences have counterfactual
scope thus a heit B therefore be moved
holds not only for actual billiard balls
but also for counterfactual billiard
balls PA op PB not PA therefore PB holds
not just for actual mushrooms but also
for counter effectual mushrooms both
have counterfactual scope but do they
have the same scope and if not why
not I'm not looking for an answer that
relies on our intuition so usually don't
believe in intuitions I'm looking for a
theoretically systematic precise
informative and correct answer to arrive
at such an answer I will turn to
invariance and to make the answer more
informative I will move to New examples
in particular I would like to use an ex
an example of a logical inference that
has a richer logical structure and an
example of a causal inference that is
related to a General law of nature such
as Newton's law of
gravitation my examples will be five for
some X PX or not or QX for all X not QX
therefore for some X PX somewhat similar
but we have here
quantification something is P or Q
nothing is q therefore something is
p six some kind of inference from
Gravity to motion for example gravity
causes the Free Fall of objects near the
surface of the
Earth I will
show that five The Logical inference is
based on a connection in the world
between properties that have maximal
degree of invariance and this means that
it itself has a maximal counterfactual
scope and that means that it has a
maximal modal force that is
necessity I will also show that six the
a causal inference is based on a
connection in the world between
properties that have non maximal
invariant therefore they have non
maximal although significant counter
factual scope and non maximal yet
significant modal force or
necessity
invariance invariance is a central topic
of Interest both in science and in logic
and Mathematics there are many types of
invariance for example invariance of
laws of nature and Replacements of
frames of reference here I will focus on
invariance of properties under
Replacements of
individuals to prevent
misunderstanding let me clarify that I
use the H term property in its everyday
sense not as a philosophical term of art
such as universal and I'm also not
interested in the ontological status of
properties here what I say here is
compatible with different ontological
accounts of
properties now properties in general are
selective and they the selective in
nature they distinguish between some
objects but not all example the property
is a human distinguishes between me and
my laptop but not between me and
Alex or between my laptop and the number
one neither of them have have this
property so it doesn't distinguish
between them the property is a woman
does distinguish between me and Alex but
not between me and Priya or between Alex
and the number
one I will say that is a human is
invariant under Replacements of Me by
Alex and of Mount say Mount Everest by
by one but not by a replacement of me or
Alex by one or Everest in general a
first level property p is invariant
under Replacements of individuals that
have it by individuals that have it and
and by individuals that don't have it by
individuals that don't have it but not
by individuals that have it by and
individuals that don't have it
so this is very general and simple more
precisely I will talk about invariance
of properties under on toone
Replacements of
individuals or if I take domains into
account under one to one to one and onto
Replacements of
individuals for example in the
domains
um Gila Alex and the number one one one
domain and second priia my laptop and
Mount Everest is a woman is invariant
under the oneto one and onto replacement
R which goes from me to priia and from
Alex to my laptop and from Everest to
the number one but not under the one to
one and onto replacement our Prime that
goes from me to my laptop from Al X to
one and from Everest to
priia that is only replacement that lead
us from things that are women to things
that are women or things that are not
women to things that are not women now
we are ready to proceed to maximal
invariance maximal
invariance while the properties we
looked at so far are invariant under
some are the properties okay while the
properties we looked at so far are
invariant under some one to one and onto
Replacements they are not invariant
under all but some properties are
invariant and they're all one to one and
onto Replacements of individuals these
properties are maximally
invariant example is identical to take
any individuals a and replace them by
any individuals in a one to one manner
you rep replace a by R A and B by RB it
is easy to see that identity is
preserved a is identical to B if and
only if r a is identical to
RB if we have a numerous domains this
holds across domains where R is one to
one and on two so identity is maximally
invariant
the second level property non proper non
emptiness or non empty is also maximally
invariant this property is the property
denoted by the existential quantifier
when we say for sum X PX what we say is
that the property p is not empty so the
denotation of the existential quantifier
is the second level property is non
empty now take any any two equin
numerous domains D1 and D2 take any one
to one and onto replacement R from D1 to
D2 take any first level property p and
D1 and look at the image of p p Prime
under R it is easy to see that P is non
empty in D1 even only if its image under
a onetoone Replacements of the
individuals is non empty in
D2 so is non empty is also maximally
invariant and we have the result
one all the logical properties that is
those that are denoted by The Logical
constants such as identity a
complementation in a given domain
denoted by negation in a context like
PX a intersection Union inclusion
nonemptiness and UN universality in a
given domain they are all maximally
invariant second result no physical
properties are maximally
invariant one way to see that is to note
that they are not invariant under one to
one and onto replacement ments of
physical individuals by mathematical
individuals for example numbers all
physical individuals are subject to
gravity but numbers are not and
similarly for all other physical
properties next
result maximal invariance entails large
counterfactual scope which entails
strong
necessity maximal invariance of property
entails stronger counterfactual scope of
in of inferences based on them then of
inferences based on non maximally
invariant
properties it follows from this result
counterfactual scope of logical
inferences is greater than the
counterfactual scope of causal
inferences but the difference between
them is only a matter of
degree now let me explain this all show
that this is the case let us first
explain this result by means of an
example and then
theoretically The Logical inference we
had before for some X PX or QX for all X
not QX therefore for some X PX is
logically valid because in the world the
nonemptiness existential quantifier of
the Union disjunction of two properties
and The Emptiness of the second for all
xn is connected by a formal regularity
to the nonemptiness of the first
property now this holds in all actual
counterfactual domains of individuals
that is in all domains of either actual
or counterfactual
individuals therefore the counterfactual
scope of this inference hence its model
scope is very
high another way to represent this on
the level of the world the lowest level
ER where we look at actual and
counterfactual individuals we have a
regularity a formal regularity or law
non emptiness of the Union of p and Q
and emptiness of Q guarantees or brings
about or necessitates nonemptiness of PE
this ensures that on the level of truth
the truth of the two premises guarantees
the truth of the conclusion and this
guarantees that the inference for some X
PX or QX for all X not QX therefore for
some X PX is logically valid this
explains why the above influence
transmits truth from premises to
conclusions and does so with a strong
necessity note a note on the scope of
maximally invariant properties and
inferences based on this
logical or formal properties do not
distinguish between individuals that are
physically possible and physically
impossible from their point of view
there's no difference between them and
even between individuals that are
metaphysically possible and
metaphysically
impossible example from a formal or
logical perspective a ball that is both
all red and and blue is just as possible
and just as subject to formal and
logical
regularities as a ball that is both all
red and small from the point of view of
The Logical properties there's no
difference between being all red and
blue and being all red and small it
simply doesn't it abstracts from all
such
differences therefore the count per
factual scope of logical inferences
includes individuals that are both all
red and all blue all red and blue this
is not the case for causal inferences
which are based on connections that
apply to domains of actual
counterfactual physical individuals but
not to other kinds of
individuals question but how exactly is
maximal inval an connected to maximal
necessity answer if a property does not
distinguish between two individuals the
laws or regularities governing or
describing it cannot distinguish between
them either otherwise it will not be a
law or regularity of this property they
apply to one even only if they apply to
the other now if p is a maximally
invariant property it does not
distinguish between any individuals
actual or
counterfactuals where the scope of
counter factual is broader than
physical physical counter
effectuality therefore the scope of the
laws or regularities governing
describing TP is also broader than the
scope of physical laws
regularities and the inferences based on
them are also so very
strong now what about causal inferences
and the L regularities grounding them
take the inferences from Gravity to
motion that we mentioned earlier while
the property is subject to gravity some
gravity greater or smaller is not
maximally invariant in the actual
counterfactual
sphere as so associated with logical and
formal properties it is maximally
invariance in the smaller actual
counterfactual sphere of physically
possible individuals all physical
individuals actual and counter effectual
are subject to
gravity in contrast the property is a
human or is a homo sapiens is not
maximally invariant in the physical
Sphere for that reason inferences
grounded in laws regularity governing or
describing gravity have a strong
counterfactual stronger counterfactual
scope than influences grounded grounded
in laws or regularity governing or
descri describing
Humanity but weaker than logical
inferences which are grounded in formal
laws formal or logical laws and
regularities so logical inference are
strongest maximal invariance maximally
necessary physical inferences and
physical laws have a lower degree of
invariance lower degree of necessity but
they can still have a significant degree
of necessity such that the laws of
gravity or inferences based on these
regularities and others too can have
some counterfactual scope but a smaller
one
conclusion both logical and causal or
physical inferences are grounded in
certain laws regularities that hold of
some actual counterfactual
individuals therefore both have a
certain modal Force but due to the fact
that logical inferences are grounded in
laws regularities that govern or
describe maximally invariant properties
while causal inferences are grounded in
laws
regularities that govern or describe non
maximal non maximally invariant
properties the counterfactual hence
modal scope of logical inferences is
greater than that of causal inferences
thank
you
we have time for some questions I if
there are questions from people who
haven't asked yet I'll take those first
if not please and then yes thank you
very much I was wondering if you could
say something more about the
contrafactual
mushroom as an example uh okay
um the counter effectual let me give you
sort of another example I happen to have
two children now it is I could have had
three and I could have said and there is
a sense in which it is true to say that
my counter third counterfactual the the
person who is the third counterfactual
child is a counterfactual child of
mine H I think that in general when we
talk and and so we and we always talk
about counterfactual situations and
counterfactual object counterfactual
things should I build this machine or
that machine if I build this one and not
this this is a counterfactual machine
that maybe I could have built now I
think that it's very important to
understand to take into account
counterfactual objects when you think
when you want to understand
properties why first for some properties
you they have different degrees of
invariance they distinguish between
different things and so there are
difference this is a significant
difference between them but H in the
actual World they may not I think qu
likes the example of has a heart and has
a kidney or something like this it just
so happens that in the actual world if
we take into account only actual
individuals they have the same
invariances
but if you want to understand the
difference between them you have to go
beyond it h but even more than that if
you take the a property of gravity for
example in order to understand gravity
we have to understand that had Earth had
Moon a counterfactual moon it would also
be subject to Gravity by Earth and we
cannot understand gravity I think well
if we don't understand that and so in
general in order to
understand properties and then the laws
that govern them we have to understand
how they would behave if something that
is not the case were the case so that's
where I get to counterfactual objects
and including a counterfactual
b
so in my everyday experience uh and uh
at the experience of people I know quite
often inferences come after delay you
look at on work on something think about
something nothing works you wake up in
the morning brush your teeth and here's
an answer what mechanism does it involve
it's clearly not a causal or it's not uh
language related uh what mechanism
involves there and a broader question I
mean I appreciate this logic uh it's all
logical but uh what kind of mechanisms
uh humans use to come up with inferences
ah okay yeah so I think both the
question you asked are for me they are
connected yes um I think that knowledge
in general depends both on how the world
is and on how our mind works we can only
know the world through the prism of our
mind uh of our cognitive resources
and so H in the case of influences that
you talked about as a result of
undergoing this a complex situation in
which we both look in the world and use
all our cognitive resources and come to
know the world better and better we can
see connections between things in the
world and it is seeing the connection
between different things in the world
that lead us to make inferences about
this subject matter sometimes the
connection we see are formal and then
the inferences will be logical or
mathematical sometimes the H connection
will seize like a connection between ASP
taking aspirin and fever going down and
then we will realize that in the world
there's a connection between certain
components of these two phenomena and we
we we we draw an
inference and so generally I think when
we look at it going to your second
question how do we get to influences so
the way I look at it is this I mean
human wants to know the world as it is
but we have many
limitations um we make mistakes we are
cognitive capacities are limited so we
need something that distinguishes
between correctness and incorrectness so
we introduce the concept of Truth and we
also um have limited time we cannot
always just H um establish individually
every think every statement we want to
establish so we look for shortcuts and
inferences are shortcuts H in inferences
it's enough to establish the premise and
establish the connection to other things
and then you get the conclusion and you
don't have to examine it
separately and H I think that humans are
have the ability to H detect formal
regularities in the world for example H
they can see if you take some physical
properties some properties are reflexive
that's a formal feature of a property
some are symmetric some are Transit
some are not and H you can say you you
can see that if you
have a property um which is a transitive
it doesn't have to be symmetric but if
you have a property which is both
symmetric and reflexive and the universe
is limited you can get
transitivity and so we can um figure out
Formal Connections between properties we
can figure out cardinality connections
we can say that H for example um the
cardinality of people in this room is
maybe I don't know 30 40 something like
this not zero not 100 and we can draw
connections between 40 and cardinality
20 and say that it's second the the
first is larger than the second and so
on and so we observe regularities in the
world including formal regularities and
I think that's how we get to logical
inferences and we observe regularities
in general or Connections in general and
that's how we get to other kinds of
inferences we can take one was first and
then we will need to stop but those of
you who want to stay and talk a little
bit more we have time before dinner
naali then we than speaker
and as well uh yes thanks so much for
your talk uh so I'd like the notion of
maximal invariance but I'm still having
a really hard time wrapping my head
around formal
regularities and especially the notion
of formal regularities being something
in the world and maybe one way to put
the thing that I'm yeah sort of a bit
bothered by you might think that
actually maximum in variance would
actually count against formal
regularities being in the world I mean
the thought just being is that if these
logical truths could apply to a totally
fictional world or even a world that's
you know I mean I mean it sort of seems
to take away from the notion that these
are actually in the world in some sense
so so I don't know if I'm just begging
the question and you know adopting what
would take to be the more traditional
view about logical truths being true in
virtue of form but I still it still
attracts me and I'm maybe you can help
me okay so first let me say something
about formal regul Po ities in the world
H first perhaps I will mention another
result which is an interesting result
not
obvious um it turns out that all higher
level mathematical properties are
maximally
invariant but aside from Identity and a
few others H all first order lower level
mathematical properties and mathematical
individuals are not maximally
invariant now this is relevant to how we
think about the formal today we very
often think about the formal the
mathematical as first level and we think
about individuals one two three and we
can say well we have no evidence for
their being in the world and so we need
to be platonist in order to accept that
and we don't want it let's just go with
a linguistic interpretation of
mathematics and logic and so
on but now what I'm talking about is
mostly properties of properties even if
you start just with physical individuals
you are Huma and even you start just
with their physical
properties it is a fact that in the same
way that in this room this room has the
feature that the are men in it and women
in it they also has the feature that
there are 40 humans in it rather than a
million or zero it's just a fact and
it's a formal fact about this situation
it is a formal fact about the relation
of X sits next to
Y that this relation which is
instantiated in this world in in this
room is is symmetric but not
transitive so it is sort of there are
formal effects they are not on the level
of individual numbers and their
properties they are on the level of
largely second and higher level
properties of physical and other
properties now how do you reconcile this
higher level formality with the fact
that we do mathematics usually first
level in terms of individuals like
numbers my own explanation is and this
is part of what I said um before how we
know the world depends on our mind and
on the world it it is very likely that
human beings are such that it's easier
for them to figure out relations between
say cardinality properties when you
think they think about them in terms of
structures of of individuals and their
properties numbers and their properties
rather than properties of properties of
properties that will explain why we talk
in terms of first order terms which is
very different to connect them really to
reality but they are systematically
correlated to these higher level terms
formal terms that it's very easy to
connect them to reality so that's how I
sort of think that H the formal is in
the world and I'll just say one more
sentence that even if you take the
physical I mean gravity is in the world
even though it has certain
counterfactual scope so just because it
holds of counterfactual physical object
doesn't mean that it's not in the world
I don't think about counterfactual
situations as other worlds or possible
words it's a way to represent to ourself
a certain force and a certain stability
and generality that some properties have
so that's how I look at
it thank
[Applause]
you